ce sont des habitués de la montagne les
voilà désormais à magny-les-hameaux 11
moutons élu domicile à côté du parc des
sports jacques anquetil avec une mission
simple et écologique pâturer et
remplacer des machines parfois limité
intellectuellement une tondeuse ça fait
que avancé alors qu'un bouton ben ça
al'avantage de réfléchir parce que bath
a un cerveau par exemple ils mangent pas
les orchidées ils mangent pas les
narcisses les primevères donc ça fait
des prairies à fleurs plus écologique
plus économique le pâturage naturel est
une pratique devenue fréquente dans de
nombreuses communes pour s'installer à
magny les hameaux les moutons ont
parcouru près de 2 km en ville avec pour
berger une quinzaine d'enfants déjà par
rapport à la nature parce que bon on y
voit la nature de notre d'un autre oeil
et puis ils sont vraiment obtenu un but
à avoir du bruit des voitures des
tracteurs des camions qui ne pense pas
que la moto on peut à mouton ou de
chèvre on peut la mener pour simplement
tourner la pose de jardin de chez papa
pour l'occasion les enfants étaient
également invités à réaliser des nids
pour les oiseaux avec de la laine une
après-midi forcément pédagogique pour
tous